[Musique]
je vous écoute racontez moi ce qui vous
arrive il y à peu près deux mois notre
fils daniel commencé à avoir des crises
là les yeux grands ouverts alors qu'il
est endormi il essaie de dire quelque
chose mais tout son corps est paralysée
daniel tu fais ce qu'on appelle des
paralysies du sommeil tu imagines une
présence effrayante dans ta chambre
ce n'est que dans ta tête
c'est ton imagination mais il n'est pas
le seul ces cauchemars on les fait tous
les quatre
vous allez dormir dans la même pièce que
vos parents vous vous sentirez en
sécurité nous pourrons garder un oeil
sur vous pendant votre sommeil
il y avait quelque chose avec nous dans
la pièce je veux bien être pendu ce rêve
ça arrive quand je m'endors c'est comme
une ombre
le cauchemar fantômes existent depuis
depuis que l'homme a pris à rêver
cette vermine se glisse dans votre
sommeil elle paralyse le sommeil de
l'enfant pour pouvoir l'écraser mais dès
les mois à venir promet des verts
à
non